President Trump has made it clear he
will use his attacks on the
congresswoman as an issue in the 2020
campaign it's not the first time he's
been accused of racist language at
O'Keefe is in Des Moines Iowa where the
Democratic candidates are weighing in at
how is this issue playing out on the
campaign trail
well Jerry good good morning Democratic
presidential candidates get asked
everyday heck some of them get asked
every few hours about something the
president has done or said sometimes
they try to brush it off and change the
subject but not this time
those were racist tweets but from day
one of his presidential campaign they're
bringing crime they're rapists and ever
since a total and complete shutdown of
Muslims entering the United States the
president has repeatedly stoked racial
tensions Democratic frontrunner Joe
Biden said it's not just the president
who he disagrees with what do you say to
Americans who might agree with what the
president tweeted yesterday I said so
you'd say that the voters I'd say that
anybody who's that racist erase that
machine of a racist president Trump
refused to back down in part because he
believes his supporters will stand by
him many that we heard from yesterday do
I know you don't like his tweets and
they think he's crass and it's
unfortunate he had to do the way he had
to do it doing the only way he can to
get this country back if you think you
have it better in your where you came
from or with how they did things there
go back where you came from in a sign of
how these racial tensions are being
observed around the world the senior
administration official confirms to CBS
News that Russia is still meddling in US
politics mostly through social media by
stoking these racial divisions the Trump
administration has told Russia to quote
knock it off but that senior
administration official says there's no
sign there doing that just yet
Gale all right thank you very much